[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la comédie musicale grease le soir ça va
être magnifique
merci vraiment vraiment même la coiffure
vous voit bien surtout et et moi j'aime
bien c'est la même mois sont ravis voit
ces jo ira t-il travolta vous allez
faire une petite démonstration d'accord
devant l isi et votre partenaire vous ai
choisis qui isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gerdemann à la voix
[Applaudissements]
nous étions le 23 janvier
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
julien pour moi il est le meilleur qu'à
voir ce que vous aurez essayé en tout
cas alors à bas les i
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]